[Applause]
yo
let's talk about uh dax foot because
that's a little crazy situation you
gotta be hurt right now
that was painful quarterback for
quarterback four dallas cowboys i'm born
and raised in dallas i'm a cowboy fan
watching the game all of a sudden
indestructible his whole career
like that was my big argument for dad
cause this guy never gets hurt
and i always knew it's gonna take some
freak [ __ ] for him to finally set out
again
he did not get again this is where it's
interesting this is where it's
interesting so he got franchise
a franchise tag means you get like a
guaranteed amount of money for one year
and it's the top five in your position
the average of the top five players so
the top five quarterbacks in the league
they average those salaries
and then for one year you get that
amount of money 31.4 million dollars
and the team is allowed to franchise i
believe one player
a year and then you can keep franchising
but the price keeps going up to such a
degree that it's not worth it it's not
worth it
so they franchised them last year from
that mistake they were trying to
i think the cowboys were offering like
35 million a year for four years
no five years dak was like i want four
i'm not signing less than
for more than four years i want less
less years because there's going to be a
tv negotiation like renegotiation
and the price that fox is going to pay
to carry the games
is going to lift up the salary cap super
high and i can cash out again
right so he's like uh fine franchise me
i'll get 31.4 million this year i'm good
and then next year
i will get the big contract done or i'll
get a franchise tag for even more money
like 40 million or whatever then all of
a sudden the first time in his career he
gets injured and it's the freak injury
of the ankle going the complete the foot
going the complete other way
yeah dislocated broken compound fracture
bone sticking through the skin
and that [ __ ] i don't think i understood
how crazy it was he just
goes down immediately starts waving to
the trainers and his foot's just
sticking the wrong way
and he tries to like plant it around the
end of the ground and get it the right
way
and i was just like looking like this i
don't think i understood what was going
on and then you see the medical cart
his teammates are all freaking out the
[ __ ] his old head coach is on the
other team sideline he's a coordinator
he comes over checks on deck and then
when you see
dak crying as he's being carted off
that's when you're like oh [ __ ]
this guy that's when it hit me like this
guy's watching his entire career past
before his eyes and i thought as much as
it sucks to talk about and you wish he
got his money the interesting thing is
the contract negotiation because next
year even if his ankle heals you don't
know how it's going to look until you
see him on a football field
this is a crazy freak injury gordon
hayward is apparently the closest
comparison
gordon hayward doesn't look the same
i'm a fan of dak i want dak to get his
money i'm also a fan of the cowboys i
want the cowboys to be good
in the nfl you can only spend a certain
amount of money every year so my two
sides of
a fan of both are like i want him to get
his money i
don't know if i want the cowboys to pay
it necessarily so i'll just uh
show this screen grab because we can't
play yeah this is the [ __ ]
his foot is can you go back a little bit
al just so we can see
this is just crazy man
oh that's just freak yeah yeah it's a
freak accident yeah
it's not a bad tackle or anything no
nothing dirty
nothing dirty it just just so happens
that the guy who is tackling him his
knee
rolls over his ankle during the tackle
yeah i mean dude if he tackled him
one step earlier his other foot
would be by that knee and it would go
right i have been thinking about this
because this is and this
deck also oh my god by all accounts
great guy
lost his mom a few years ago to cancer
his brother committed suicide
last year he talked about how he's been
depressed he's been struggling with
mental health
everybody is like i watched a video you
sent me from a doctor talking he's like
you really got to worry about his mental
health
he's already suffered struggled with
depression now he can't play the game he
loves
people need to keep checking on this guy
you're worried about him
then there's a fan part of me that's
like do we want to pay this [ __ ]
come on guys what are we gonna talk
about this so i just thought
as [ __ ] as it was this is the only
place i know
where we could have that conversation of
like what do you do with this guy next
year now what is the deal like
it looked like his foot is kind of
turned out like
it's turned the complete wrong way like
he already walked lebron
footed whatever now it's that [ __ ] is
already now it's a [ __ ] 90 degrees
it was a total break yeah you ca
honestly as [ __ ] up as this
is you can't pay him man i think you've
got a c
you can't pay him you got to see now
somebody else could take that gamble and
you could potentially lose that
but if you're part of an organization is
and again as [ __ ] up as it is
this is the gamble this is the gamble
you take you take now
you want to turn down 35 million dollars
a year or whatever it was for five years
you have that right yeah but you are
playing the most dangerous sport
yeah in existence yeah you are playing
the position that every single play
the other team is trying to tear down
100
right not a single play offensively goes
by yeah
without the other team going that guy's
getting the ball first
and we are tying to concussion 100 we're
trying to kill this we're trying to kill
this get him out of the game
that's it if we can i want to deal with
him
you turned out 35 million because you
believe you are worth more and that's
totally fine
but that is the gamble and i think it's
what i would have done i think i'd have
been like nah [ __ ] it let's take the
risk who cares 31.4 million i'm good
with the rest of my life anyway i'll be
honest with you bro he must have a lot
of money
because the only way you could turn that
[ __ ] down
is if you have [ __ ] you money already i
don't know if this is true i've heard
this
have heard it disputed i heard he made
50 million off advertisements already
like just being the cowboys quarterback
that could be a [ __ ] figure if
that's true then you're like i'll take a
31 million who is a [ __ ]
but dave chappelle said it best
everybody says what's the difference
between
10 million and 50 million he goes i'll
tell you what it's a staggering 40
million dollars
if your deck was the difference between
80 million and 150 million it's a
staggering 70 million dollars
so that's just the interest you can live
with it
you can see what i'm saying like if this
was his first contract
he's taking that [ __ ] in a heartbeat
yeah but the fact that he's gotten 50
million maybe in endorsements and he
this year alone he got what 31.4
31 guaranteed that's [ __ ] you money
forever exactly so he can say [ __ ] you
forever if he never plays another down a
football
him and his kids will be amazing yeah
and he's in texas where are you not
paying no [ __ ] tax on that's just
cheap boy
that [ __ ] is cheap that's why everybody
want to be quarterback of the dallas
county
i can't believe you incorporated here
that's crazy i know i'm stupid but
that was the part that i was i've been
thinking about that financially
miranda's got punches
but that's the thing i keep thinking
about is the money because i'm indian
but i'm like yo this guy turned down 100
million guaranteed
and he took that risk that i think i
would have taken and he got
[ __ ] it's it might be over how many
teams are going to save money because of
this in the offseason
because they're going to be other
quarterbacks yeah buddy that are going
to go
oh boy yeah i'll sign yeah i'll sign
we're talking an extra 10 20 million
whatever but you've got a hundred
million guaranteeds
it's kind of like isaiah thomas say what
kind of feels like uh isaiah
t man yeah remember the basketball yeah
100 yeah
the there's a uh do you remember uh
demar derozan
yeah remember him he played for the
wrath and he got signed
uh he was playing great he was gonna get
signed
he was asking for a max contract and
apparently the raptors came to him
with under the max and
he couldn't say no to it
maybe there weren't other offers out
there and maybe the raptors knew that
who knows exactly maybe other teams
weren't reaching out but
this is a guy who comes from i think
it's compton i think
compton and is being offered instead of
150 140 million dollars yeah
are you really gonna say no to 140 wait
but he couldn't say no he couldn't say
yes he couldn't say no he signed it yeah
he couldn't say
no oh even though it wasn't a max there
was that 10 million dollar gap
yeah i think when it's in front of you
and you know what you came from
i actually hard bro you know what as
you're seeing where you're making you
that's your first bill no no and i'm
agreeing about to agree with demar i'm
about to flip
positions i think if i'm in that
position actually i'm thinking
it's ten million dollars either way i'm
it's [ __ ] you money forever forever
forever
ever i'm equivalent over 10 million sign
the [ __ ] deal i'll make it up
it's a little disrespectful i'll say
that [ __ ] a couple times make myself
feel better
call it out in the media a couple times
be passive or do the opposite i want to
put that money into our offensive line i
want guys to get paid you could be the
good guy with it too
you could be but that that actually i
think i might have taken the kind but
either way football player take the
goddamn money
if it's not disrespectful take it and if
it's guaranteed
oh yeah that's what they care about is
how much is guaranteed so you could drop
it
and i think you wanted a little more
guarantee but i think they had like 100
million guaranteed i think
anyway look get better dak man it's um
this is a shame bro that [ __ ] was rough
to watch that's heartbreaking man and
seeing a football player cry dog the
amount of pain these guys take on a day
to day
to see a guy like that cry you're like
yo he's going through hell bro i feel
like you were tearing up too
just talking about it i might have been
man first of all i'd be crying all the
time
second of all this guy's emotional bro
this guy's life isn't
[ __ ] it's in a dark place bro nah if
you lose a game you love and your
brother and your mom like it's not
completely fine
yeah this guy going through it yeah yeah
i guess if you put it like that
yeah if you make it all sad then yeah
why did you make it all sad
are you telling me i gotta make you want
to cry did you make it fun instead of
sad
yeah i'm trying to point out why i'm
fine now his foot will make him turn
directions better he's black
wow let's make it fun let's do something
no no no no just so we're clear the dad
is black that's okay
he's half black wait dad where is the
deck
i thought i answered the question
we have a father and he's like in my
life like for real for us you know that
that's why you are you that's why you're
so amazing it's like we found just cause
you call your boyfriend daddy it don't
count
hey i'm going to taylor
you